All right. I'm very excited for my fourth
toxic Google to welcome Kari Byron.
Best known of course for the
Discovery Channel Show mythbusters.
But she's done many,
many things since for over a decade.
She's been a strong presence in the world
of reality based science television.
She's hosted thrill factor,
head rush, Pumpkin chunking,
large and dangerous rocket
ships. Ldrs. Super Cool. Uh,
so you spent a lifetime occurring odd
skills and interests after graduating
college as an artist.
She traveled the world,
decided to settle in San Francisco
to pursue a career as a sculptor,
which is amazing. Um, but ended
up discovering the handling poop,
eating bugs,
wiring,
explosives and scraping chicken guts
off the ceiling was a real dream job.
Perfect resume for Google.
All right.
I'm very excited to
welcome Carrie to Google.
Oh
well thanks for bringing me out here
from the bay area. So for me,
I've watched Google grow. I mean,
I came here with Jamie for a photo shoot
you guys had when it was like an open
floor with some cubicles and I was so
impressed because you had a candy wall.
You have grown a lot.
Yeah.
So before talking about everything
had been up to since mythbusters,
I have to ask,
is your job as insanely fun as it appears
or are you just some terrific actor?
Well, I'm definitely not a terrific actor
and if you look at early mythbusters,
you can tell how nervous and
awkward and bad I am at talking.
It is really, really obvious.
My job is actually very,
very fun and that is one
thing that we always had.
His mythbusters was one of the
few shows that was on reality.
That was actual reality when we were
hurt, we were hurt. When we're happy,
we're happy and you know, you're doing
some really fun, interesting stuff.
And when it was boring they
would just edit it out. So
no, and even with all the set up,
because all the shows you've done,
there's a lot of stuff that gets filmed
and Diane are not film behind the scenes.
Is that stuff's still fun
or is there any part of it,
this kind of like a drag when you hear
actors talking about the hours of waiting
in the trail or in the drudgery
and making a film? Was it all fun?
Well, you know, we were
all friends. Um, and,
and we actually had chemistry so we,
before we all had angry birds so that
everybody would ignore each other.
We had these really fun games that we
would do when say there was some sort of
safety protocol. Like, you know,
the bomb squad had a full hour that
they had to wait and we were stuck in a
bunker.
We would come up with old timey games,
like throw the rock at the can and we
would have so much fun trying to see who
could hit the can. Like
we, we always had fun.
Even when some of the
things kind of dragged on,
we all had a very similar senses of humor,
which slowly got lower and darker
because that's what happens when you get
familiar with people and we all just
kept each other very much in stitches.
Cool.
You on to college for Film and sculpture,
your most well known for
your science or programming.
How has your background as an artist
influenced how you communicate science?
Well, you know, I come
from a long line of,
of Sciencey and rd people and I
feel like they are in the same vein.
It's all about fostering a
curiosity. You know, with,
with art you're taking an idea and you're
trying to explore it in a visual way
that um,
helps you come to some sort of conclusion
or feeling about that question.
And Science is the same thing.
It's just exploring your curiosity.
The difference is, I feel like over
time science became very sort of,
you know,
when I was growing up almost like clinical
where it was identifying the parts of
a cell.
Whereas when it really gets fun is the
way we did it on mythbusters is where
you'd get really dirty and you get your
hands on it and you do it the way you do
art. You know, you're, you're throwing
a pot, you're getting your hands in the,
in the Google.
So that kind of builds into this question
is there's a perception among some
that science is not a creative in Denver
that creative people pursue the arts.
What have you learned about
science, especially past
what you get in high school?
Um, about the creativity of scientists
and those persons that pursue science?
Well,
I think it's pretty obvious in the tech
community you guys have figured it out
that a great diversity actually comes
to a better space in solving any sort of
problems. So when you bring
an artist into, you know,
a scientific field or vice versa, you
come up with the most beautiful things,
look at kinetic sculptures.
When you take science and apply it to
art and you make these incredible moving
pieces, I think it works the same way.
You just have a different approach.
And a, over the years I've learned
that art and science are pretty much
is there mashed inner and you've also
emceed some amazing events showcasing
students sign in addition, the
White House science fair, uh,
to the vex world championships
and Disneyworld. A super cool.
What have you learned from the students
that you've met over the years?
Never under estimate young people because
they are so much more sophisticated
then I was as a kid and,
and when you talk to a 12 year old,
you talked to him like there are 35 year
old, you know, it's, it's, it's, um,
I've learned so much from them and their
experiences because everyone at that
age is so honest and will tell you
exactly what's happening and they're so
creative and the world's just so open
and it's just such a beautiful way to
approach it. And I think
sometimes as we get older, we,
we lose that need to be fascinated.
Well, I can tell you, we have, we have
thousands of interns every summer.
If you were probably in
the audience right now.
And it's amazing what
interns can accomplish before
they've even finished, uh,
have finished their college degree.
Very true.
So a lot of them has written about how
you visited mythbusters and never left,
uh,
for students that have no
idea what they're planning
to do with their lives when
they grow up.
What have you learned about making
the most of unexpected opportunities?
Well,
I feel like I was almost too young when
I went to college to truly appreciate it.
I, I mean, that might be pretty universal,
but I don't think that I was
the kind of person that, uh,
took advantage of it the way I probably
would now for me when I was traveling,
um,
that's where I really learned how to
say why not and to go for opportunities
because I was traveling alone around
the world. I hadn't, you know,
I had friend to start with,
but then we went our separate ways and
it was just the sort of thing where you
just have to, even if it's
scary, you have to try it.
And I feel like that is what led me into
mythbusters to start with because I,
you know,
I tried advertising and I was bored and
I tried all these different careers and
I just couldn't find myself. And I came
to mythbusters in my late twenties,
but I was ready to just work
for free. I was like, you know,
I will be an intern because I want to
do sculpture and special effects seems
like an easy fit because you
guys get paid to do sculptures.
How did I know it was a
dying art? Uh, the time,
the practical effects were just crumbling
beneath the crushing computer industry,
but I really,
really wanted to learn how
to have an interesting life.
And so I thought if I just do it for free,
sooner or later I will prove myself
worthy and maybe they'll pay me.
You had a long road with miss busters
was never a point where you wavered or it
got old or,
or did you just manage to have this
incredible long run where it was fun the
whole time?
I mean it, it, it changed
along the way. It was, it,
it's peak fund when we had the least
amount of cooks in the kitchen where we
were just allowed to run with it
and kind of do what we wanted.
Whenever any buddy tried to mess with
the formula and try to figure out what
makes it popular and do more of that,
you know that that was
always a little hard.
Like for a while they kept trying to
make us fight. They would, they would,
you know, like all those
chopper shows were so popular.
So they would take me aside.
This was back when Scotty was
there to take me aside and be like,
Scotty said about what you did.
You know what she said about your field,
and then she takes
Scotty's. I'd be like, Oh,
this is what Carrie just said about you.
And they try to get us to fight and
be like, oh, you're probably right.
Your way is better. And
they're like, no, no,
never works. We're fallen
for it. We liked each other.
So you've already brought up
the diversity is so important.
Combining sciences and
technology and gender,
so specifically about getting
more women to pursue stem,
which is a huge priority of Google
and we've got a long way to go.
And we've been very public about that.
It's persistent challenge.
What have you learned
about inspiring kids?
Especially girls to ignore those
stereotypes or look beyond them.
I mean, I feel like we've made a
lot of progress. I mean a long,
not too distant past. I was, you know,
would've been chaining myself to other
women trying to get the right to vote.
And then my mom's generation
was burning their bras,
trying to get me to go to college. And
now we're here where, you know, when,
I don't remember seeing a lot of women
in dynamic scientific positions on TV.
If they were in a doctor,
they were the nurse. They were
never the, the scientists.
They were never the smart one.
And now every TV show you look at,
you see actual women represented
in smart scientific fields.
And you know, maybe by the time my
daughter's a grown up superhero,
women won't have to fight in high heels.
Like I feel like progress is being made.
Um,
I know that when I,
I don't know if I'm an
expert in this at all.
I do know that the girls I talked to with
the White House science fair seem like
they were, they had it
down. They, you know,
I asked them what got you into it and
they all had these great stories of
triumph to get to where they were.
But mostly supportive parents,
especially a supportive dad was
really, really important. Um,
the having role models they could look
at like people like Ellen stolen from
NASA. Like you know, seeing women like
that succeeding was, was really important.
Seeing themselves reflected in the media
was very important but also mostly it
was being able to find like minds.
You may be the only girl in the
math club at your small school,
but there's another only girl
in Minnesota in the math club.
And if you guys can get online,
which is the beauty of the Internet,
you can actually connect,
you can feel that support and maybe you
can help each other stay because I feel
like people get interested in things but
fall away when it's hard or when they
feel like an outsider.
And if you're the only girl you
might feel like an outsider.
So you got to network
and help each other out.
We as women also have a tendency to
compete and tear each other down and we've
been raised that way.
Whereas I think we're trying very
hard to start being supportive.
Like every time I meet a woman
trying to get into my industry,
people are always trying to pit me against
them. Like, ah, she's trying to be like,
you were her shows not as good. I'm like,
there's a woman on TV, are you kidding?
I'm going to call her and if we can
help each other, this will be great.
I wouldn't be where I am
without people like uh,
Debbie Myers from science channels.
She's like,
let's do a show that inspires girls.
Let's do it. She helps me out.
I'll help her out anytime she needs it.
Cool.
You've always struck me,
we were talking about this before
about being an accidental celebrity.
By that I mean you didn't,
you didn't do theater.
I tried to Google it and then I asked
though theater, no theater background.
You weren't designed to be a star, you
know, so you were at an accidental.
You gain celebrity status waiting until
you're past about how different is real
world carry from the brand carry and is
there any difference in you even think
about that?
Um, TV characters, a lot more. Makeup,
clothes are generally tied her
on TV I think because, well,
or maybe that's just because
of moving parts for machinery.
I don't want to get hurt. I wear a lot
less dresses on TV. That's about it.
But other than that, Byron we see
on mythbusters and pumpkin shape.
That is you feel like you're
able to be who you are?
Yeah, I mean, I, I didn't, when
we started, uh, mythbusters, it's,
it's not like you have audience like this,
which would have been
incredibly intimidating.
You have a camera crew that you're
friends with and it's almost like making a
home movie. And so it just
slowly became part of what I did.
And I don't live in the
Hollywood structure as well,
so I don't do red carpets
in that kind of fun stuff,
except for maybe once a year I get invited
to something special and I'll go down
to la.
So I think that maybe that would have
fed me more of the celebritiness but
no, myth busters, I think you did.
You're on the red carpet for the Emmy's.
Mythbusters never didn't want to
got nominated ton. Did it ever win?
Now far if mythbusters won an Emmy,
total crime,
what would be your acceptance speech?
Oh, they would let me get back.
The small amount of time I talked.
So much
music you get the best speech has
got the music. Yeah. All right,
so the internet does not have a great
track record when it comes to the online
treatment of women. How has your
experience been with the online world?
Um,
at first I had to get a thicker skin
because we had message boards that we were
encouraged to be very interactive with
our audience because that was what made
mythbusters different is that our
audience was part of us. And um,
you know, I got my feelings hurt
really easily when people would,
I remember somebody called me a bubble
head and I cry. I mean, it's just,
it's just silly insole. But it was
just, you know, [inaudible] was,
it was a little tough,
but I grew a really thick skin and I
just don't read that stuff and I kind of
laugh at it now. You
just don't engage. Um,
and you definitely don't Google your
name with the words feet or butt
or you in any male Costar or
sort of more positive like you've
been on David Letterman show.
It's a while back. Google
it. It was my first nervous.
I can tell you, you were amped up. I
was playing my dress the whole time.
My feet were sweating. You opposed
to science for, as I mentioned,
the White House medical events.
What is the coolest door that's been
open because of getting some celebrity?
Oh my God, the White
House. I mean, I got it.
I got invited to host though White
House science fair because they were,
there was an emphasis on women and girls
and I was so humbled by the experience.
It was so incredible.
I got to do this panel with some
really incredible women and some,
some girls that had made it to the science
fair and hear all their stories and
we just got to sit around and talk.
And I walked away from there just in awe.
And then the president said my name
out loud, my mom and dad could hear,
which was amazing.
And then they ushered me off to a little
secret room with like teen came in and
all these fancy people.
And then the president comes over
and gives me a hug and I'm just like,
oh,
this is so crazy.
And then at one point I had
to go look for the bathroom.
They just let me walk
around the White House.
Like I would just walking
around looking for bathroom,
like kind of looking for
some like monogrammed m and
m's or something to steal.
But you didn't. But then like John
Kerry just walks past me on his phone.
That's pretty hard to top up degree.
Um,
so mythbusters head rush,
you've had a chance to recreate
and test some cool science.
What is the most unexpected results that
you can choose? Just one surprised you.
It was not what you're planning
you. There's so many different ones.
And I've talked about him a lot.
Like a bull in a China shop.
I couldn't believe bowls were graceful
complete elephants were actually afraid
of mice.
I couldn't believe that an ancient
Chinese system using drums buried in the
ground actually would, uh, trigger,
you could hear somebody tunneling from
far away from this old ancient system.
Um, but the most surprising I had was,
I don't think I've ever talked about it,
but, uh, on head rush, um,
I had a science advisor that had this
experiment for me where it was making a
heating water in sort of an early Meyer.
And then he told me to put a lid on it.
I was like, I feel like that's
a pressure vessel, but you know,
I didn't hear the science guy
and my gut kept telling me,
this is a bad idea. This is
a really bad idea. He's like,
no, no, no, no, no, no. Well,
I've done this before. I've done it
a million times. So I'm like, okay,
he's the scientist. What do
I know? So I, I made the,
this experiment, I put my head down
close because they want to get a shot.
And then I stood up and it exploded and
it burned across my stomach so that the
skin fell off.
And I have like a kind of a scar,
the shape of a wolf, which
is kind of cool. But it was,
it was a really important
moment for me because it,
it shook me because I feel like there's
this psychology that you think of,
the camera's rolling. You can't
get hurt if the camera's rolling.
Nothing can go wrong.
And I also,
I didn't trust my gut
and I only got hurt in a,
in a really uncomfortable way right
before you have to go on vacation to a
Hawaiian island
because the skin was coming
off. But, uh, it was,
it was a small price to pay for a
new awareness where I could realize,
okay, you've got to actually stay
safe even if the camera's are rolling.
Trust your gut. And just because
somebody has the credentials,
it doesn't mean they're right.
So I'm gonna ask a couple more questions
and open it up to the Googlers.
So start thinking, ask good questions. Uh,
so on a Pumpkin chunking and Ldrs,
you've had the chance to meet some
really interesting people that,
and if you're not familiar
with pumpkin chunk,
and that's this event where you
hurl a pumpkin really, really far
by any mechanical means possible.
So we're talking catapults,
Trevor's Jay's air cannons. It
just, it, it can't be like rockets.
And they, they go almost, they've
gone over a mile, a pumpkin
and then a large and
dangerous rocket ships.
People take pretty much anything and turn
it into these ridiculous rocket ships.
And also I'm rock tips go super high.
So when you've met these both really
cool shows, check them out. Um,
what have you learned about
the people behind these crazy,
insane Stein's? Now you've had a
chance to talk to them, meet them,
like what makes them tick?
I just, I have a great respect
for anybody who follows a passion,
specially weird passions and the fact
that these gorilla engineers are just
sitting in their garage and this is their
hobby to create a huge trevorshay to
Laba pumpkin and their whole
years dedicated to that.
It's so much fun because they're,
they're the good kind of crazy, you know,
they're,
they're using,
they're using a science and engineering
in a wild and cool way and they turn it
into a family event.
Like everybody brings their kids and
kids get into the physics of it and it's,
it's some of that unintentional learning
that I always love where it's, you know,
it's, it's the cheese on the Broccoli. It
makes it taste good. I learned something.
Okay.
And on your most recent project with the
travel channel or thrill factor also,
very cool.
It looks like a blast.
How did you convince Tori to vomit and
pass out on a stunt plane to show the
effects of four?
I didn't really tell him to vomit path.
That wasn't right. It's fantastic.
And watch it.
Oh Tori and I are really good friends
and we do a lot of shows together because
it's, uh, were, were complete and total
opposite. It's like a, it's, it's,
it's really fun.
And he was the one that brought the stunt
planes to us cause he met a rich guy
that had stunt planes and he's like,
let's,
let's go out there to Vegas and do this.
And I was a little dubious cause it
seems crazy but towards a certain kind of
charm where it's,
it's sort of like his men friends kind of,
you know how men get where they,
they love each other but they
want to torture each other,
you know, all these. So,
so we go up in the plains and they,
he actually has a really great resistance
to g lock and he gets to the point of
fighter pilot before he passes out.
And I think that made the pilot
sort of challenged. He's like, Oh,
you had passed out yet,
what we're going to make you pass out.
And then after I watched Tori pass out
tamable they basically just turn off the
engines and let the plane tumbled.
And he was insane.
And I looked over like, oh my God, that's
awful, Huh? How, how do you do that?
He's like, Oh, you want to do it now?
It's like, no, no, turn off the plane.
It tumbled. Mind you, none of this made
it to air. I've suffered for nothing.
Tumbled into the plane.
And then just cute. I like,
and then as I'm getting off the
plane with my puke bag and you know,
the travel channel crews
down there, they're like, all
right. So I don't let that,
we both had to sit in a dark room for
an hour before they could do interviews
and stuff with us. And we had wanted
to the plane part out of the way.
So we didn't do any of the preliminary
stuff just yet, like walking in. And uh,
so I had to get the puke out of my hair
and get the Mascara Alec from an Emea.
It's like a pretend like
it hadn't happened yet.
So one, one final question. I'm
my hand it off to the audience.
So if you could have a cameo in one of
the following, which would you choose?
And why Star Wars,
Star Trek,
game of Thrones or Sharknado,
if it was based entirely on fashion.
The dresses and the outfits that they
wear in game of Thrones is awesome.
But the women don't fare too well.
It's a little violent.
So I mean I would clearly pick star wars
because the like layers let it then I
won't spoil news there.
They're leaders,
they're warriors and they're equals
and they get to fly. Cool planes. And
how has that movie,
because we were talking about this week,
how has that movie affected your daughter?
Like how does that,
what impact did ray have?
I have a seven year old. So,
uh, when we went to see the
movie, she had no idea. She,
she,
she hadn't watched any of the star wars.
And we went with my nephew who
was five and so excited and we,
we win to the theater and she's
like, Oh yeah, this will be cool.
And then when it turned out that ray
appeared and she was the main character,
my daughter yelled back,
everybody's laughing after that. She
went home, she made a wrapping paper,
Light Saber. And she just be, you know,
she actually threw away all her
princesses. Don't tell Disney we threw it.
We wait.
We didn't throw them away.
We took all of our princesses and we
gave them to a younger cousin and it was
all about star wars.
Cool.
That's cool. Sandy Diego to my
daughter. So. Very cool. All right,
so I have a helper here with a microphone
and the Dory. If there are any doors.
There are some. All
right, I will, I will, uh,
just go on the audience first
and I will look through the dory.
The Dory by the way,
is our internal mechanism for people
watching our lives and ask questions.
So I will look through those for
those. The livestream. Okay. All right,
so we'll go to an audience
question first. Yes, yes, yes.
I'm Erica. Hi. Um, I actually have
three daughters, seven, 10 and 12.
And um, also very similar
to you, engineering,
art sort of my whole life.
I've kind of been in there,
so I understand the desire.
Um,
I wanted to know if you have heard of
what's called she heroes because I think
that modeling is a sort of a really
key thing for our daughters. Um,
and so there's a program called she
heroes were people like you and regular
people, um, do little video clips and,
and give models to young kids,
young girls for like being cool
and being cool and science.
So I was just curious.
Yeah, I hadn't heard of it,
but I will definitely put that on my
look. Lexi's okay, cool. I'll Google it.
Google it because it's, I mean, you
involved in that I think would be awesome.
Is that Shirley use,
do I am friends with somebody who does it?
So if you the connection,
I'm happy to set you up.
Sorry.
Already.
It is a very cool program for anybody
that our first question end plug and
going to the dory.
Uh,
so what's the coolest skill you've
learned while mythbusters that you've used
outside the show?
I should,
I say
no. Like as soon as someone says,
should I seen this, the answer,
of course we need to hear it.
I, um, well as I love to do artwork,
I have,
I used to really love the impressions
that black powder would make after you
exploded.
So I do some black powder painting
now at an undisclosed location that is
completely safe and completely
legal. It's, it's, um, it's really,
it's a fun medium to work with
when you know how to do it safely.
And I learned how to do it safely and I
learned that you can get anything on the
Internet from China
for your artistic passion.
So I have to build on that because the
explosions in mythbusters in slow mo are
phenomenal. And what is your
favorite all time explosion?
Oh, that's easy. Because you know,
people always ask me about my favorite
papered explosions and you know,
there's that pushing power of Amoco
photo and then c four is sort of like a
dirty quick one. But
like I love, I can't, oh,
like it might actually be an ignition,
but when we shot guns at,
um,
a propane tank, it made this
gorgeous, billowing, fiery,
probably not great for the environment.
Cloud that in slow motion kind of roles.
And it was just beautiful that in coffee
creamer also an ignition when coffee
creamer exploded it into the
air and lit it with a flair.
Also just like a fuel based kind
of Hollywood style explosion,
the kind of thing that you actually
expect to see as an explosion.
Cool audience, I'm sure. Yes.
I'm curious what your favorite myth was
that either never actually made it to
air or never got selected to
even be done at all. Uh, we,
we've definitely had,
we had a couple that didn't make it to
air either cause they were ridiculous or
we couldn't do them.
Where we tried to do this one called
squash weight lifter where, um, the,
the idea was that one of those giant
Pumpkins from Monterey had the capacity to
lift a car if it grew
underneath it because it, it
had that kind of strength. Um,
but turns out all of us at black
thumbs and we couldn't grow anything.
And we had this like, not from gardens.
So we tried it twice, three times.
We had this garden set up with the best
hydroponics because San Francisco and
it's like crazy grow light disco den.
We had the seeds from some,
you know,
champion Pumpkin's and we couldn't
get anything bigger than this.
We try to try it. I'm like, ah.
But it was really fun because we had
that crazy garden and I enjoyed the,
it was a little zin going out
there and trying to garden,
but I guess the environment
just wasn't supporting it.
So recently Google has been doing
things like deep and Magenta
with some basic forays into AI,
creating art and music.
What would be some combinations of science
and art that are just completely psi
Phi that you would like
to see become reality?
Oh hmm.
I would like my own slave robot.
Android.
They could,
could light the explosions in my black
powder painting closer than I could.
That is a very complex question.
I like it. Um, have you ever seen,
I think they're called wind to
beasts. When debase, when base those,
those giant kinetic sculptures,
they move in the wind.
That that's my favorite kinetic
application of science to art.
I thought that was so beautiful.
It's all AI scares me though.
These aren't real people.
These are all wouldn't be surprised.
Testing the Beta tester on the scary AI.
We're going to go back.
They don't look like regular people.
How we're going to analyze the last
and make sure they were laughing.
Any appropriate party.
All right.
Scenes from mythbusters over
like, Hey, I'll do that.
You really wish what
club? Major error. Okay.
Oh, I mean, there's so many, but um,
I could tell you a super embarrassing one
that was kind of funny. Um, there was,
uh,
there was a point where we were,
we were out in the desert and
tensions were high. It was hot.
People were fighting. It got
really sort of, uh, just,
just very tense.
And so I walked up into the middle of a
tense conversation and just walked up to
grant,
went pull my finger.
They laughed very hard as I think, you
know, that means you toot, right? Yeah.
Yeah. Okay. I just felt like, I was like,
I couldn't figure out anything
to make this better. It was like
nothing better than a girl fart.
Curl cars are funnier than dog hearts.
I'm not sure how to go about that. So
I'm not going to pivot off that question.
We will get so off the dory. What advice,
we'll take a couple more questions.
What advice would you give to
a young aspiring scientists?
But I'm going to modify it a little bit.
One of the youngest
firing female scientist.
Uh,
find a mentor and find an internship.
Find someone doing what you want to be
doing because likely they will help you
out. And ever people love
talking about themselves.
I've been doing it for
like half an hour now.
You can usually get in good
with somebody and they're,
they're likely to help you out.
And everybody loves an
insurer and they work hard.
They're trying to prove themselves
and they are cheap or free.
So you can get your foot in the door,
you can get some experience.
Find out if it's what you
really want to do. And I mean,
that's how I started on mythbusters is
just a lot of exploiting free labor.
So he started with sculpture.
And now you've mentioned
like the black powder stuff,
the kinetic art is sculptured still
your now, now TV films, Cetera. Uh,
it's sculpture is still your favorite
or do you have a new favorite?
Heck, no. I love sculpture rights.
I think in three d like I am a
much better sculptor than a draw.
It's someone who draws. I, if I have an
idea of something how I want it to look,
I can make it in clay better that can,
I can draw it.
So for me it's very calming and um,
I'm a bit of a multitasker,
so I will do sculptures. Well,
I listened to podcasts or watch TV or
try to have meetings when they're on not
Skype. Um, because they
can see that and I,
I still make a lot of them and I use
them as a terrifying parental learning
tools for my daughter.
I make these things called manners,
monsters or behavior beasties to
break her of habits such as a,
for a while she wasn't each to,
when she was much smaller,
she had a tendency not
to flush the toilet.
So we made a monster that looked like
it was crawling out of the toilet that I
said, if it stays in there too
long, it comes to life. Um,
we had booger monsters that you know the
boogers in your nose and if you go in
there and steal their food,
they're going to crawl out of
your nose and look for food.
They might crawl on your ear and eat your
brain and you'll never learn to read.
So we, we make these little, I have,
I have monsters grow
almost every bad behavior.
So I've got a ton of them now and they're
creepy and little kind of timber and
you look at things and that they've,
they cured her of nail biting real fast.
All right. Who would back a Kickstarter
campaign for a boob? Wildstar
terrifying your children into good
behaviors. We're going to take them,
we'll take one more,
one more dory and one more live question.
And then we have time
for a short mean green.
So I'm going to modify this a little bit.
So what's the most dangerous thing,
not that you did on the show,
but that you didn't do on the
show because you finally here.
This would probably be too dangerous to
film anything Tori ever suggested it and
all right,
so that sounds good.
We'll bring Tory in for a followup
and that will be the leading fashion.
All right.
We had a one more to the microphone.
Back to the art side. I do follow
your black powder work. Uh,
tried to dabble a little bit in it
myself and caused a little bit more fiery
explosions probably, and not a safe
manner as you, but for the art side,
do you, you've done a lot of
advocation for technology,
engineering and all of that.
How do you feel companies like this?
Like we have a makerspace here.
Uh, it's called the garage.
And do you try to advocate that artistic
side towards a lot of those ends to
those tech sides?
Cause I feel like sometimes that's
lost when there's a lot of science and
engineering and all of that.
You might lose some that ingenuity
or the fun of arm that comes with it.
Is that something that you often see or
is there anything that advocating wise
that you do on it?
I love living in the bay area because we
are clearly a strange bubble of people
who it's, I hear it's not
stem, it's steam. We put the
art in the stem because I,
I mean mathematicians are artists
and scientists are artists and I,
I think that the maker movement is
incredible and I love how DIY and sort of
that the whole sort of Etsy generation
is kind of bringing it back to an rd form
and the maker fairs
getting bigger every year.
And it's so cool to see people applying
all of their different brains into
something even.
It's ridiculous but beautiful and cool.
I love the maker movement.
Cool.
Well, I don't want to thank you
for an awesome visit to Google.
Oh my God.
Thank you.
This has been fun to see that we fed Kairi
Jeanette to pay for the food shocker.
Um, and it took it on tour. And I was
really excited to have you here today.
Thank you very much. And good luck with,
I know the things you can't talk about,
but they can carry us some cool stuff
coming. I'll leave it at that and
we'll be talking about our new show.
Uh, this week we make an announcements,
so you may Torian grant are back together
again. And another nerdy endeavor work.